the rise in the number of cases that
we've seen today is
concerning the cases are predominantly
among younger people
but we've seen in other countries across
the world and
in europe this sort of rise in the cases
amongst younger people
leading to a rise across the population
as a whole
and it's so important that people don't
allow this illness to infect
their grandparents and to lead to the
sort of problems that we saw
earlier in the year the schools have
reopened the government has been
pleading with people to get back to work
this sort of thing happens what do you
say to those who may be
understandably concerned by these
figures well i understand
why people are concerned about figures
like these of course all
workplaces are covered secure we put a
huge amount of work into making sure
they are
the same goes for schools the rise is
predominantly amongst
younger people and it's important to
remember though
as we've seen in other countries that
younger people can infect their
grandparents and we don't want
to see the spread of this disease
because it inevitably then
leads to more hospitalizations we've got
to all do our bit and keep following
that social distancing
some people say you're bound to get more
positives because you're testing more
people
do you know what the rate per 100 000 is
that is a key figure isn't it well it's
true that we're testing more and more
people
but even the proportion that test
positive is going up as well
so we are concerned about these figures
about the rise in the number of cases
and it's so important that everybody
does their bit
and follows the social distancing
because it doesn't matter how old you
are or how affected you might be by this
disease
you can pass the disease onto others
including those
for whom it can be very serious and lead
to hospitalizations or
worse so don't pass the disease onto
your
grandparents if you're a young person
everybody needs to follow that social
distancing
now if this rise continues and we get
also more hospitalizations and
and have a bit more deaths is another
lockdown still
an option on the table well we'll take
whatever action is necessary but the
first line of defense
is that people should follow social
distancing we've also got the testing
and the tracing and they're happening at
record rates we can use and we will use
local lockdowns if that's what's
necessary
but the first line of defense for
everybody no matter who you are no
matter how old you are
is to follow that social distancing so
that we don't pass it on
to people who will end up hospitalized
or
worse now workplaces are covered secure
schools are so are covered secure it's
really important that people follow the
social distancing at all times
your critics are going to come after you
and say we told you you shouldn't reopen
the schools we shouldn't be going back
to work we should be
more cautious than we have been what
would you say to them they've got a
point haven't they
well it's really important that we've
reopened the schools because of the
impact on children of not getting
education
the the workplaces that have reopened
they are covered secure and there's
follow strong covert secure guidelines
what really matters is people follow the
social distancing in their social lives
as well because
you know that is how this disease is
passed on predominantly it's at the
moment predominantly amongst
younger people but we know that that
then leads to cases amongst older people
because people inevitably can't help but
pass the disease onto
their their family their grandparents
and we've seen that in so many other
countries
so i'm concerned about the figures but
the most important thing
is that everybody needs to follow social
distancing are you still convinced that
you and the prime minister have a grip
on this pandemic
well yes we are we've got a clear plan
we've got the first line of defense
social distancing then there's test and
trace
then if then we will go into a local
local lockdown if that's what's needed
but
everybody has a part to play and the
social distancing is a critical part of
that